good morning John's Monday about a week
ago I woke up at six o'clock in the
morning not because I had to get on a
plane I was being dragged out of bed by
some ridiculous circumstance for because
I wanted to watch the sunrise because I
had something that I haven't seen in a
while
I brushed my teeth and then I stretched
my back out for a little while because
apparently I'm a little bit too old to
lay on the ground all night without
being a little bit stiff Katherine and I
were at a working ranch in the
Centennial valley pretty close to
Wyoming pretty close to Idaho but still
in Montana there's horses and there's
cows and if there isn't nowhere in the
lower 48 to be in the middle of John we
were in the middle of it this ranch that
we were on is about a 40 mile drive away
from a place called Minh Ida Minh Ida as
you might imagine is the very creative
name of a town that is on the border of
Montana and Idaho what you might not
imagine in this thatman Ida has a
population of two people total as far as
I can tell all the man Ida has is this
amazing sagging barn that I've seen lots
of pictures of on the internet some
closed down shops and in the distance a
school bus graveyard so yes man Ida not
a bustling metropolis and we were about
50 miles away from it awaiting the
marriage of two of my favorite people so
there's no getting away from the fact
that suddenly my somewhere had become
pretty close to most people's nowhere
though apparently no matter whether
you're somewhere or nowhere there are
still 6-inch spikes of Steel that will
get embedded into your tire and you will
be extremely grateful to have a very
good spare tire because you are in the
middle of nowhere and the alternative to
changing your tire is sitting there
thirsty and hungry hoping beyond hope
that someone drives by which they might
do once every 24 hours or so and
everywhere we look there was more proof
that we were know where these giant
tanks for gasoline and diesel for
example because you know you're not
gonna drive your truck a 200 mile
round-trip to get gasoline and yeah the
outhouses were still in use because that
is just how they do things out here in
nowhere right after I filmed that
footage of those outhouses I was
bounding back to my group of friends and
stepped in a WhistlePig hole WhistlePig
look it up and I came crashing to the
ground writhing in agony trying not to
vomit from the pain and Catherine runs
up to me of course thinking oh my god
the nearest hospital is
hundred miles away it wasn't actually
500 miles away I have looked it up it's
179 miles away I had a sprained ankle
not even a very badly sprained ankle but
nonetheless driving home the idea that
this is kind of nowhere but mostly
outside because I didn't get to dance at
the wedding reception we've laid down
grids and drawn all kinds of imaginary
lines and even put satellites up in
space to prove that every place is a
place as if without that knowledge the
cows wouldn't be screaming in the fields
for their recently weaned calves that
they no longer can see making a noise
that proves to you over and over again
that cows can say a heck of a lot more
than Moo as a trumpeter swans and
sandhill cranes aren't resting here
where they can get a little bit of
respite from the insanity of human
creation just because what we see out
our windows becomes what we think of as
the world doesn't mean that there isn't
a whole globe out there just doing its
thing being itself making life possible
139 miles from the nearest hospital at
least subconsciously feels like not part
of my world and we're gonna think about
that sunrise thought I woke up to that
morning I just feel like I got as close
to nowhere as I could get and found out
that it was more of a place than
anywhere I've been in a long time John
I'll see you on Wednesday